Hey youtubers it’s Charlie, hopefully you’ve
all had a chance to see both the Flash and
Arrow this week.
This will be a combined Q&A.
I think I’ll just call it Arrow vs Flash
every week.
This will be a regular thursday Q&A unless
something crazy happens with the schedule.
In case you’re new to either show and you
haven’t read the comics before, no you don’t
absolutely have to watch both shows to understand
what’s going on.
But they share a narrative, so it will be
a lot more fun if you do watch them both.
Let’s get to some questions, careful for
spoilers from both the episodes if you haven’t
seen them yet.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go.
Question 1 - Spider Mew asks, do you think
when Laurel becomes Black Canary she’ll
get the canary cry superpower?
Question 2 - Rainheart asks, do you think
Sara is really dead or will she be back later
this season?
Question 3 - Average Wonder asks, do you think
The Atom will have shrinkage powers like in
the comics or will they do something different?
Question 4 - Vince asks, do you think laurel
will become Black Canary
this season?
Question 5 - William asks, does DC have a
contract with Microsoft because in the first
two seasons there was a ton of product placement?
Question 6 - Navish asks, there are some leaked
pictures of the reverse flash from the set.
Do you think it’s Harrison Wells or Eddie
Thawne?
Question 7 - Dawson asks, do you think bringing
Green Lantern on either of the shows would
overshadow the main characters?
Question 8 - Miguel asks, who
is Komodo?
Question 9 - Kat asks, Any suggestions for
comics to read?
Question 10 - Alfredo asks, do you think there
will be any more easter eggs for Wayne Industries
or Lexcorp or other
Justice League stuff?